how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and everything relating to the
mcu and we have
huge news today in regards to she-hulk
as we finally have
our she-hulk are jennifer walters
because she has been officially cast
a few days ago deadline reported that
marvel studios has tapped kate coiro as
the director of the she-hulk series
and as an executive producer on it as
well and now deadline is coming with
another new report stating
who marvel studios has cast as she-hulk
and real quick if you want to stay up to
date on all things relating to the mcu
be sure to subscribe to my channel
so here's the deadline report straight
from their website
after tapping cat coiro as director
marvel studios looks to have found its
star to take over the title role in its
she-hulk series
sources tell deadline that orphan black
star tatiana
mussolini is the choice to play the
title character in marvel's she-hulk
series for disney plus
so tatiana mussolini is our she-hulk
slash
jennifer walters in the upcoming
she-hulk series on disney plus
and we've learned a lot about the
she-hulk series this week it's going to
begin production in february of 2021 we
have an official director now
jessica gao has been tapped to lead the
writers room for the she-hulk series and
now we officially have our she-hulk now
word before was that marvel studios was
looking for an
alison bree type to play she-hulk slash
jennifer walters now we all thought
alison brie was going to be the actual
person to play the role
but tatiana miscellany is actually a
really excellent choice and she
definitely does fit for what they were
looking for
as far as an allison breed type goes so
there you have it tatiana miscellany is
going to be playing she-hulk slash
jennifer walters the cousin
of bruce banner the hulk let me know
what you think about this casting choice
in the comments down below
do you like this pick and the great news
is that marvel studios seems to have the
ball rolling when it comes to
advancing in their projects and moving
along the way we've gotten a lot of news
this week that we haven't gotten in a
long time and it seems like we're only
going to be getting more
which is awesome news so don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on everything relating
to the mcu as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof
you